yeah actually um i'll be starting
something accountable like when you
discuss okay i'm so sorry
all right so um thank you everyone for
joining today um let me make sure i'm
sharing yeah can everybody see my screen
yes yeah we can see your screen
all right
okay so um today i will start by giving
an introduction
telling you briefly about what we do and
how
you can kind of benefit from
what we do on a regular basis today is
an example and it's really designed for
people that are going to be applying
some of these methods to a data set so
um what we will try to cover today is a
little introduction to omixlogic as a
community
and as a
resource that you can leverage either
for
doing research learning about different
methods of analysis or helping others so
if you're a faculty member
or you
are teaching maybe a teacher
these are resources that you can
leverage and so today's session is
actually an extraction from a
program that we run regularly
this program right now is ongoing for
louisiana biomedical research network
and for members of the national
association of idea principal
investigators and this program is
typically uh conducted as a three months
course
where we introduce statistical analysis
and machine learning methods we talk
about how to design experiments and how
to validate the findings and we talked
about how to apply different types of
methods of machine learning like data
mining and
different ways to apply supervised
machine learning by classification
network analysis and others
so the program typically addresses
several different important issues with
machine learning so a lot of the work
to get data prepared for machine
learning is an important part of knowing
how to deal with different types of
structured and unstructured data
it is important to understand the
difference between signal and noise and
for that purpose we have a number of
exercises that are applied to different
types of omics data which i will explain
in detail today and then we talk about
this challenge of data complexity or big
data volume complexity
heterogeneity and how machine learning
really helps us to
extract meaningful
insights from such data sets and learn
about the links between biology and data
so how to really
get some insights from such data
so who is this for these programs that
we design are really
made
in such a way that anyone that has
minimal background in data science can
benefit from such programs and today i
hope will be an example of how anyone
with
just kind of basic understanding of some
of these topics can get much further
ahead can really learn and practice and
get some practical experience
with uh these complex methods and so
hopefully after today's session you will
kind of see
as a perspective into the data science
and machine learning uh how this can
apply also for other methods and other
types of data
so the goal of my part of the session is
to really talk about
the need for data science and machine
learning for biologists i mean why is it
an important topic what are some of the
important things to consider
how to use it in your research in your
publications if you're just getting
started how to get started
i will also talk about some of the
challenges with the type of data that
you are commonly going to encounter and
i will explain our approach of teaching
bioinformatics to explain how you can
quickly go from raw unstructured data to
something that you can use and then in
the second part of this presentation uh
raghav will explain how you can actually
practice and practically analyze such
data using some examples
we will also talk about the logic behind
the analysis and introduce the resource
that helps
kind of structure the logic in a
in a way that you can follow and
practice more
and then we will talk about some of the
bigger challenges with machine learning
specifically
why it's important to understand the
methods in detail and not only learn how
to run them so why is it important to
understand the meaning behind the
different settings or being able to
explain and validate some of the
findings
that you have done using machine
learning
so
let's start by briefly introducing data
science and kind of talking about where
machine learning fits in into this
more broad topic of data science how
does this relate to biological and
biomedical data so commonly what you
will find is that data science is
described as the intersection of
data statistics
and some specialization domains so we
can talk about
data storage
data formats how to manipulate data we
can talk about different analytical
methods like hypothesis testing and then
typically there's a domain that you
apply these tools to and so in each one
of these you can distill them into these
specific challenges
for analysis it is difficult difficulty
of extracting signal from noisy data
sets
for data we'll talk about the
differences between structured and
unstructured data and the challenges of
making data structured so that you can
easily apply analysis methods to them
and then for specialization domain in
every domain
whether it be biological research or
financial modeling the importance is
annotation and validation so
understanding some data is more
intuitive than others and in the
biomedical or biological domain we need
to rely on annotation and validation
using databases
bioinformatics is typically described as
the intersection of statistical analysis
informatics and biology and so
really what it is is the application of
data science to the biological domain
and in this biological domain we have
several different applications like
basic research
biotechnology agriculture genetics
biomedicine etc etc so really when we
look at the two of these together we can
kind of see that the intersection really
only changes by specialization so
biology is more specific
for bioinformatics and data science is
just more agnostic and so the question
is how does machine learning fit into
this scheme so machine learning is
really the intersection of statistics
and mathematics and computer science and
machines in this case are algorithms or
models that we can train and they rely
on statistical methods and principles
right in reality many of the things that
we call artificial intelligence and
machine learning they leverage a lot of
the statistical analyses that have been
around for a long time what has changed
are the advances in computational
infrastructure
and as a result of that some of the
things that were not possible previously
are now possible
and so machine learning sits at the
intersection and really what we're going
to be talking today as
machine learning for biological and
biomedical data are the sub
kind of
portions of machine learning which are
unsupervised machine learning supervised
machine learning methods deep learning
explainable and interpretable right how
do we actually take these models analyze
using these models complex data sets and
then know how to explain them know how
to apply them properly and validate that
what we're finding is really true signal
and not noise
so to begin
speaking about this i think we need to
start from talking about data
so
why is it called data science and why
does machine learning fall under data
science so data typically comes
as um a collection of um you know some
kind of digital signal and data science
is the study of the signal and so when
we talk about data
majority of the data that you will find
is actually unstructured and so the
first
90 of your time that you're going to be
spending with data is really
converting this unstructured data to
structured data which is a table or a
matrix or a data frame
and once you do that you want to find
associations in this data and there are
going to be many associations in the
data some of them relevant and some of
them not and so studying associations
within that data are typically going to
result in some kind of a model
and that model is what we will
talk about today
how to differentiate between these
models and how to then extract from
these models some meaning
so
the process
from unstructured data to maybe
semi-structured data where you have
many different components and you are
trying to understand relationships
between them to then finally structure
data and that structured data is
something that now is going to be easy
for you to analyze and extract some
meaningful relationships and those are
going to be what we will talk about
today because they should be reportable
and actionable
now one of the major trends in
biomedical research and biological data
is the exponential growth of data that
is now available for anyone to access
and so what we will do today is we will
take a few examples on these data sets
but as you will find it's very easy to
find data
in fact in just this pandemic we just
kind of did this
chart at the beginning of the pandemic
and we found that the number of genomes
submitted during this pandemic is
many times more than in previous
pandemics that have been recorded and in
particular this is because
data generation
is cheaper more accessible and more
useful and so machine learning is
especially important because now we are
able to collect data very quickly and
this data is large and unstructured so
when we talk about genomes for example
these are nucleotide sequences and so
it's not easy to analyze the sequences
why well to explain why i have this very
brief example so here's an example of
unstructured data on one hand and how we
tend to look at data to be able to
interpret it so unstructured data in
this case is an example for a chat
an exchange on chat
so you can see that we have a date uh we
have different names here of users and
we have their responses and these are
responses to questions so for example if
i ask the question what is your degree
what is you know your highest level of
education
any person here can answer in multiple
different ways someone will say i have a
bachelor's someone will say i have a
master's degree in bioinformatics
somebody will say you know high school
somebody will say yes right just because
they are answering a different question
so as a result they have this collection
of unstructured data which are just
texts and my objective to try to
interpret that will be to categorize
them assign them to different groups and
measure the number of responses per
group so that makes it interpretable
right when i look at this chart i can
quickly understand what this exchange
really boils down to
and that is the challenge in structuring
data that also comes from biology or
biomedical research what kinds of data
do we have in biology and biomedical
research that need to be structured
we have imaging
streaming data for example video
different types of omics data
chemical interactions
clinical records and different types of
phenotypic
data for example cell morphology so all
of these
have to be converted to a series of data
frames and the objective of preparing
the data for analysis is really knowing
how in each one of these these are very
different types of data imaging video
data genomic data right they're very
different when we obtain them
how to process them in such a way that
we can end up with a data frame
that aligns the different samples or
pieces of information
and gives them features and so this is
what we're going to be working with
today
today we're going to be looking at
omnics data
so when we say omix what do we really
mean by that there are many different
types of omics data and what makes them
omix data is that they are generated by
high throughput automated technologies
like sequencing and they could really be
used to explore different types of
biological processes
in molecular and cell biology we
typically look at
how the phenotype for example self
morphology or function
is defined by the code of the dna
and the transcription of that code
into proteins and so
we will look at sequencing the dna for
example nucleotides in the dna
epigenomic regulation
how we can
you know detect dna methylation patterns
or chromatin
packing signals
and see the transcription of that code
into functional proteins
so
the challenge to create a structured
data set is to really take that
sequencing data different types of
sequencing data or different types of
omics data and
make them into a structured format which
is going to be a data frame and so what
we'll do today is we'll take a few
examples of such pipelines that process
data from their raw format the way that
they come out of a sequencer for example
and structuring them into a table
once the table exists or many tables
exist now we can perform statistical
analysis and really
identify important trends for biomedical
or biological questions
what kinds of questions
well here we have a few examples right
this is kind of translational biomedical
research typically you're going to be
asking the question
about patients how are these patients
grouped
how are they different by response to
different treatments how can i
categorize or stratify diseases
sometimes these questions are population
health sometimes they are personalized
individual
disease progression for an individual
patient
sometimes we want to take it further and
we want to say well based on our
understanding of data how do i intervene
are there specific targets are there
specific
interactions between drugs are there
specific
diagnostic conclusions based on these
types a bit right so these are the types
of questions that we're going to be
asking today we're going to look at some
of these examples so that we understand
machine learning in the context of
answering questions with data
onyx logic as a whole the resource and
the reason why sonarika asked you all to
sign up at the beginning of the session
is because we're going to be leveraging
some of the methods that are described
in detail on the portal and you will
have access to analytical tools that you
can try to run such analyses and get
from raw data to structured to then
interpretable
and the onyx logic portal is a complete
roadmap for data science and application
to biomedical research data where you
will find different data sets you will
be able to explore and visualize them
and understand those methods
and hopefully get enough insights and
understanding about these topics so that
you can then apply them to a research
project of your own and that is really
the idea behind all mixed logic and the
reason why we're doing a lot of these
webinars and workshops is to introduce
you to the resources so that you can
start learning on your own
in the portal you will find
detailed explanations about every single
type of omics data that you are
typically going to be working with
including multi-omics integration so the
process of exploring these different
types of regulation
leads us to the need of integrating
these different types of signals
together and machine learning is
oftentimes used for multi-homic
integration as well and so that is why
we're going to talk about several
different examples like genomic data
transcriptomic data and metagenomic data
so that we can understand the
relationships between these biological
phenomena and how machine learning plays
a role in each one of those
in terms of applications you can start
thinking about how these are applied in
oncology infectious diseases
neuroscience and biotechnology and on
the portal you will find project
examples coming from all of these
domains where you can practice some of
these methods and see how they are used
by people that are experts in the field
that have published and that have
produced important insights using such
data what kinds of projects are these
some of these projects are diagnostic
type projects so for example how do you
identify patterns associated with a
specific disease sometimes we take a
look at complex single cell data and we
try to extract meaning from different
types of tissue composition that are
typically composed of different types of
cells
or we can find associations or
relationships for example association
between microbiome composition and
infection
today however we will use two specific
examples and these are going to be two
data sets
so malika if you could already paste the
links
in chat to
these specific
projects
um
these projects are modeling cancer
precision medicine which is a collection
of cell lines that represent different
subtypes of breast cancer
and an example from tcga the cancer
genome atlas where we will find
data on liver cancer
but in addition to this on the portal
you will be able to find many different
examples including examples from papers
thank you and so in the chat you will
find a link and that link is the tcga
liver cancer precision oncology
okay
so
how
do we use
analytical methods to extract insights
from data sets like these
the typical
flow of information
you know for someone who is doing stitch
research is to have
data
that is cleaned and prepared
explored in the red right here in the
middle
and then
ready to ask specific questions or
testing your hypothesis and so as we
look at these different types of project
examples or data examples we should be
also thinking
why were these data generated right what
was the reason why these data was
generated and we will find that both of
these examples do not follow the
standard process from experimental
design where an experimentalist came up
with a hypothesis
and said to test this hypothesis
i want to now analyze i want to now
create data right to test this
hypothesis both of these examples were
generated without a hypothesis
they were just a collection of different
types of cell lines or just patients
that all fell into this great category
or general category of cancer patients
and so because this is the nature of
data sets
we have to rely on exploring the data
sets first or mining these data sets
first to come up with a hypothesis come
up with a question
and once we find this question now we
can turn to uh different types of models
that will help us get inference and
inference really means that i can find
some pattern and i can find the
application of this pattern to the
greater population
and in the context of that
a lot of people start turning to machine
learning
for a very specific reason most of these
data sets do not have
a control
versus a condition they have many
conditions they have many phenotypic
categories and to be able to ask
questions about many categories we have
to turn or it we will benefit from
turning to using machine learning
because it really provides us with that
flexibility and with greater sensitivity
and because of that
the use of machine learning and biology
has been growing exponentially
so here is a chart from a publication
uh the publication is called
recommendations for machine learning
validation biology and basically this
paper talks about how the benefits of
machine learning the sensitivity of
machine learning and the ability to use
machine learning easily has led to
adoption of machine learning across the
specter of biological
uh biological research and biomedical
research
and the problem that they have
identified is that this exponential
growth in use of
machine learning also comes with a
negative effect and that is a growing
number of papers that actually don't
apply in the evaluation of their results
because
in many cases you have two major
categories of users and those are
biologists
that now use machine learning to
identify signal
or computer scientists that really don't
have the biological background they use
these tools because they understand the
value of these tools
but in many cases unfortunately that
leads to this gap of no validation and
no independent test sets to kind of
validate the findings and a lot of times
no biological validation either
so as a result of that
the downside of machine learning is that
it's so easy to use it is so
meaningful in many cases
you have to understand the methods
really clearly and you have to
understand the settings of these methods
and then you have to understand how to
validate your findings and that is going
to be a critical portion of today's and
future workshops for us to not only know
about machine learning but also know how
to use it properly
and
with that you know there are also
many many different methods from
unsupervised to supervised to
semi-supervised
to deep learning and so when we look at
these methods we're going to be able to
compare and contrast those methods we'll
be able to understand the benefits and
the limitations of each one of those
methods and hopefully we will also be
able to understand how to extract from
these methods reliable insights that we
can interpret and we can use in our
research
and that's not always simple because in
many cases the biological principles of
for example control versus condition
don't always apply
to the data sets that we're going to be
using and so here is an example gene
expression profiles
in a particular data set that has
multiple groups that cluster together
don't always
follow this expectation of differential
genome expression right and these kinds
of problems are going to be common
across the spectrum of data sets that
we're going to be using in a session
like today where we will look at
different types of bioinformatics
pipelines we'll look at how to
incorporate them so that we can get
structured data and then start asking
questions about relationships between
clinical and our mixed data
for diagnostic and therapeutic design
purposes
and furthermore
you can actually see how once these data
sets are clear and these principles are
clear you can actually start scaling up
the application of machine learning to a
process where you automate this whole
pipeline
and you get
interesting insights about predicting
a particular
feature or category using such models so
we'll talk briefly about this how to
deploy a model to production at the end
of these workshops
now so nalika already introduced you to
the platform and i just want to clarify
how we're going to use these different
tools so i talked a little bit about
omixlogic the portal where you will find
the datasets you will find additional
resources to help learn about these
different types of data but i also want
to speak about the platform briefly so
once you sign up on the omixlogic portal
you automatically get a profile on this
portal that you will be able to run
pipelines on and these pipelines are
going to be something that you will
learn
the logic of analysis you'll be able to
use big data so uh
you know practicing or kind of doing
your research
and you'll be able to apply
many different types of analysis quickly
so that you are not hindered by the
technical complexities of each one of
these types of data
in addition there's a section called
data mining where you will find
different methods of supervising and
supervised analysis that we will be able
to try in today's session and then
download the results as uh the result of
the output of the pipeline as well as
scripts that run these analyses and
explore them now in the pipelines you
will find this logic
following a
color-coded explanation so in each
pop-up you will find an explanation
about the specific methods that you've
used and those explanations are also
going to be consistent across many
different types of methods
in addition to this as i mentioned once
you run a pipeline you'll be able to
download the script
and those scripts could be practiced on
our coding plot playground so this
coding playground
is going to help you practice
syntax
and introduce you to challenges and so
once you understand the syntax you'll be
able to practice on those challenges and
really understand how to write code
independently or how to at least modify
code independently
we
know that one of the most popular
languages today is python and in the
biomedical and biology community r is
also a very popular math
scripting language so we are going to
limit ourselves to just those two python
and r that doesn't mean that others
cannot be used but in our
sessions we're going to be using python
and r
to for those of you that are new to
python and r you can really get started
with r and python by looking at some of
the coursework that we have available uh
just to understand the syntax understand
how these languages work
and then we
we kind of introduced the context of
data science
and then uh go from statistical analysis
to machine learning
and so in the course twerk that kind of
follows what we're going to be doing
today
we have these parallel courses
called bioml and we have three of these
courses bioml
the logic behind machine learning biomel
in python and biometal and r and all of
them will explore these challenges
data wrangling
machine learning and statistics for high
throughput data unsupervised and
supervised types of analysis machine
learning for data visualization
then detailed review of methods for
clustering methods for supervised
machine learning or classification
feature selection and signatures and
then regression and generalized linear
models and finally deep learning so if
you want to go through all of these
topics we recommend getting started with
these courses and so briefly i will just
show you
where to find these courses on the
portal
so if you're on the portal together with
me
and you kind of go back to the menu you
can click on the course tab
and type in here bio ml and so you will
find here these three courses that i
just mentioned bio ml logic biomel
python and biomelr
and
if you want to participate in these
courses anyone even with a free
registration can get started so if you
want to get started you will find inside
lessons
many of them are free so you can go in
and get started with learning about some
of these methods
and
you will find also that once you've
started the course you'll be able to go
to your profile
and see that under the courses that you
have started right here
okay so with that
let me pass this on to dr
raghav
who is going to be
speaking